thank you
all right so tonight if you believe it
Democrats they were appalled that anyone
would ever question the results of any
election they would never themselves do
anything like that they value democracy
too much
really let's go to the videotape
I believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president I think it's also
critical to understand that as I've been
telling candidates who have come to see
me you can run the best campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you I think he's an illegitimate
president that didn't really win so how
do you you know fight against that in
2020 you are absolutely right the
president is an illegitimate racist
occupying the White House the Russian uh
uh uh weighing in on the election the
Russian attempt to have the election and
frankly the FBI is weighing in on the
election I think make the make it makes
his election illegitimate illegitimate
and my biggest
biggest is that he's going to do it
again with the help
with the help and that is terrifying
it's terrifying would you be my vice
presidential candidate
folks look I absolutely agree we had
this little election back in 2018.
and despite the final tally and the
inauguration and the situation we find
ourselves in I do have one very
affirmative statement to make
we won
I believe
was a stolen election and I'm not saying
they stole it from me they stole it from
the voters of Georgia
uh joining us now is the author of the
upcoming book The Democratic party hates
America he also hosts life liberty to
live in APM on Sunday night right here
on Fox the great one Mark Levin what a
shock Mark they even talked about some
of them uh alternate electors at some
point uh I played that on my radio show
today
that's the funny thing about this
Democrat Party it does hate America it's
hated America since its founding
it helped cause the Civil War and
segregation when all the way into the
1960s it supported Eugenics now it
supports abortion on demand
hates this country we've gone through
several years where they attacked the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution
and it's the voting system that they
crave they put out this hr-1 which would
destroy all the protections against
fraud and elections if you dare say
anything you're the denier let me
explain something about Georgia and all
the rest of it every one of these damn
phony indictments where they dust off
these old laws or they take what is
normal actions in the course of an
election where you're lobbying state
legislatures where you're claiming
elections are wrong whether they're
wrong or not whether you're raising
legitimate things or not
this is an attack on the people every
indictment is an attack on our freedom
our ability to vote the Democrats don't
care about voting they care about
winning
at all costs the Democrat Party wants to
be the Monopoly party in this country it
is very close to being that it wants to
be the state party where the government
and the Democrat Party are tied at the
hip they already have that when it comes
to the administrative state that means
when they're out of office they still
run the country when they're in office
they expand the non-elected parts of the
government it was John Adams who said
when the people lose their virtue
they're going to lose their freedom
one of the greatest constitutions ever
written in the world was the Soviet
constitution written by Joseph Stalin it
meant nothing it was a genocidal
dictatorship
so everything in there meant nothing how
can a party that hates the Constitution
that hates the limits that it places on
their economic agenda their political
gender and their governing agenda how
can a party that trashes the
independence of the Supreme Court
threaten Supreme Court Justices how can
a party that wants to not only increase
the number of Democrats in the Senate by
hooking by crook by adding two more
States get rid of the filibuster rules
so they can oppose their will don't tell
me they're standing for we the people
don't tell me that this is the party we
count on to protect the vote don't tell
me that this is the party protecting
documents and emails and texts when it's
the party of Hillary Clinton that
destroyed thirty thousand of them and
was never charged with obstruction don't
tell me that these bums believe in
classified information when the jerk
prosecute in Washington DC's been
leaking information related to
classified information and Bill Clinton
is still free to run the countryside
when he had classified classified
information in his sock drawers this
isn't even about any of this this is
about a political party that sees its
opportunity to seize control to destroy
the Constitutional construct to embrace
these nut marxists in their party to
push their Equity agenda to control
prosecutions to control what is just we
don't have a justice system America you
know Sean you and others keep saying me
with two justices no we don't we have a
no justice system
we may have a judge well that looks
pretty good we call them your honor they
wear black robes and we bow down to them
we have a grand jury system that's
supposed to protect a defendant which we
know is actually a tool of the
prosecution and in the cities we know
it's loaded with Democrats there's no
VOD deer or anything like that those are
prosecution prosecuted Democrats uh we
have prosecutors Soros Democrats with
the guy they dragged back from the Hague
who looks like he should be tried in the
head quite frankly who has destroyed one
individual after another and that's a
resume enhancer with the mob guy who's
running the Department of Justice right
now and then of course we have trial
juries in Democrat cities wow we got a
prosecutor a judge Rules of Evidence a
jury that looks so
so importantly judicial
it's crap
they've destroyed our justice system
just as our destroying our Republic
destroying our voting system destroying
our sovereignty destroying women's votes
censorship destroying Free Speech
destroying the right to protest ask the
pro-lifers attacking Faith ask the
Catholics and on and on and on this is
the Democrat Party every part of our
culture every part of our society right
now is under attack this is a revolution
people better wake the hell up every
Revolution doesn't have to be violent in
fact some of the some of the more
brilliant Communists said in a country
like the United States or in the Western
countries you're not going to have the
proletariate rising up you're not going
to have the middle class rising up it's
got to be top down you got to take over
the culture you got to take over the
bureaucracy and slowly but surely impose
your will that's what's happening what
they're doing to Donald Trump they're
doing to America they're doing to the
American people and I don't know if
we're going to claw away out of it but
enough of our fellow citizens better
understand that this is about them and
their Liberty that's it I'm done
all right Mark's book coming out soon
right there Democratic party hates
America amazon.com hannity.com bookstore
soon we'll let you know hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else